bonjour drieu godefridi merci de
répondre à nos questions directes sur rt
france dans le cadre de l'otan donc la
france va envoyer des troupes en estonie
à quelques kilomètres de la frontière
russe est depuis l'annnonce de florence
parly lire sur twitter c'est le silence
médiatique ppe-de annonces dans les
médias pourquoi
écoutez je pense qu'il faut laisser le
temps aux experts géopolitique dans les
différentes rédactions de digérer la
nouvelle
par ailleurs est ce tellement surprenant
c'est qu'il ya une relation accidenté je
dirais entre la france et le temps
depuis a depuis le général de gaulle
mais je ne vois rien de révolutionnaire
en soi dans cette annonce il ya
effectivement une une position qui est
parfois comme dante et parfois je dirais
offensive de la part de le ton à l'égard
de la russie
mais je dois rien dans cette annonce en
temps quels qu'ils soient
révolutionnaire très concrètement quel
est le but de cette manoeuvre de l'otan
côté à je ne vous apprendrai rien en
vous disant que la plupart du temps
lorsqu'on est en situation lorsqu'on
n'est pas en situation de guerre
effective il y à un jeu du chat et de la
souris un jeu d'intimidation et de mise
en scène respectives donc ici on a
régulièrement le temps qui en quelque
sorte
rappel à la russie sa présence dans la
région qui la met en garde contre toute
nouvelle initiative je dirais
belliqueuse ou offensive
c'est big up puisqu'en l'occurrence il
n'y a pas de guerre on a vu la france et
la russie
pourtant ces derniers temps multiplié
les rencontres
pas plus tard qu'hier
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
qui a rencontré dany ce moment le tour
of le ministre de l'industrie du
commerce russe
quel message paris on voit à moscou avec
tout cela je pense deux choses d'abord
ce message extrêmement confus à l'image
de la politique étrangère en général de
monsieur macron puisque aussi bien
monsieur macron la france a un rapport
privilégié avec l'otan et un temps de
cela croix ne cesse de multiplier les
déclarations extrêmement offensive
contre le temps comme organisation et
contre le grand frère américain en
particulier
donc il ya là une très grande confusion
dans le message français spécifique et
il ya également un effet de brouiller le
message général de l'otan puisque la
france que tout de même aux simples
temps en tout cas moi sur le plan verbal
une position également en partie sur le
plan militaire c'est 1,1 par rapport aux
saisines enfin par rapport aux autres
états européens la france a de vraies
capacités militaires
elle brouille le message de l'otan en
général alors la deuxième chose
peut-être qui est à signaler c'est que
ce n'est pas très important parce que du
point de vue ruche
la position du gouvernement américain
tutélaire au sein de l'otan est
importante je crois pas que la position
où la pétition changeant d'ailleurs à
damas et maquereau en tant que tel et la
moindre importance aux yeux de la russie
dernière question de révèle freddy la
création de l'otan remonte en fait à la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale
le but initial était d'être prêts
militairement contre un éventuel conflit
avec l'ex urss
quel est le but aujourd'hui de l'otan à
l'époque c'était pas l'ex urss à
l'époque l'urss était effectivement bien
vivante et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que le temps a parfaitement rempli
ses fonctions puisque rappelons qu'après
la guerre staline a annexé une partie
substantielle de leur art et qu'il ne se
serait peut être pas arrêtée à l'europe
centrale si le temps n'était pas n'était
pas là je dirais pour le maintenir à
distance donc le temps a parfaitement de
ce point de vue là un jeu 100 euros
maintenant la difficulté bon
effectivement il reste devrait tensions
géopolitiques entre la russie et les
pays d'europe de l'ouest et l'amérique
donc en tant que tel le temps ne paraît
pas nécessairement dépasser crois que le
vrai des filles pour le temps
aujourd'hui était d'ailleurs très
intéressant c'est le sort de la turquie
en est une turquie qui à la fois sur le
fond et internes géopolitique s'est
totalement désolidarisé et de l'europe
et des états unis
le fait que monsieur trump est une
politique assez offensive et dur permet
de monter un monsieur erdogan dans
certains imitent enfin il est clair que
pour le reste c'est quelqu'un qui joue
une partition strictement nationales
voire nationaliste et impérialiste et en
même temps on ne peut pas exclure la
culture qui y purement et simplement de
l'otan parce que si on l'exclût le lundi
le mardi et l'ira se jeter dans les bras
de la russie donc là le vrai défi je
dirais je pense que sur ce plan un
monsieur macron a raison le vrai défi
aujourd'hui pour le temps c'est de
trouver une solution structurelle et
durable à la situation de la turquie
merci drieu godefridi d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
à docteur en philosophie et auteur de
reload comment l'amérique invente le
siècle aux éditions texte qui